vier jahre trump haben amerika an den
abgrund geführt
der traum aller feinde amerikas und der
demokratie und 400.000 menschen sterben
bis zum ende seiner amtszeit an cobit
kein land hat mehr tote zu beklagen
mehr als 25 millionen amerikaner hungern
sind angewiesen auf lebensmittelhilfen
die arbeitslosigkeit auf rekordniveau
und dann mitten in der pandemie breche
im ganzen land unruhen aus als george
wright von einem weißen polizisten vor
laufender kamera langsam umgebracht wird
der präsident aber versucht gar nicht
erst zu helfen und zu heilen spaltet
weiter stellt sich fast bedingungslos
hinter polizei und sicherheitskräfte
macht immer wieder allein die black lips
matter bewegung für die unruhen
verantwortlich
lange leugne der das ausmaß und die
gefährlichkeit der pandemie und ihre
folgen
alles sei aufgebauscht eine verschwörung
der medien und seiner politischen gegner
die ihn zu fall bringen wollten
wer twitter forderte er seine anhänger
auf demokratisch regierten bundesstaaten
die strengere kontakt regeln zur
bekämpfung der pandemie einführen zu
befreien und seine anhänger folgen ihm
schwer bewaffnete milizen besetzten
lokale parlamente in michigan kann das
fbi im oktober vergangenen jahres in
letzter sekunde verhindern dass rechte
terroristen die gouverneuren entführen
und möglicherweise hinrichten und er
schafft es mit seinen lügen über
wahlbetrug das millionen amerikaner den
glauben an ihre demokratie verlieren und
das eigene politische system bekämpfen
nach vier jahren seiner präsidentschaft
ist amerika tiefer gespalten
trump aber das geschäft von amerikas
gegnern erledigt so die sprecherin des
us repräsentantenhauses putins ziel war
und ist es das ansehen der demokratie in
der welt zu beschädigen
donald trump ist seit langer zeit sein
steigbügelhalter ich habe es dem
präsidenten schon einmal gesagt mit
ihnen messer präsident führen alle wege
zumuten
putin will die demokratie untergraben
bei sich zu hause und in der welt und
der präsident hat ihn gestern das größte
aller geschenke gemacht
gnadenlos truck donald trump einen keil
zwischen amerika und seine verbündeten
und tief hinein in die amerikanische
gesellschaft erfolgreich darin dieses
land zu spalten
aber es ist als wären wir bereits ein
marmor oder granit block mit großen
rissen gewesen als er auftaucht und er
hat mit kein und hammer diesen blog
auseinander geschlagen das hat gezeigt
wie gespalten wir schon vorher waren
michael antonio ist trump biograf kennt
donald trump seit jahrzehnten hat ihn
immer wieder interviews es gibt nicht
viele die sich intensiver mit donald
trump beschäftigt haben
moskau russland mitte der 80er jahre es
ist eine zeit des umbruchs in der
sowjetunion es ist die zeit von glasnost
und perestroika die sowjetunion steht
vor enormen wirtschaftlichen
herausforderungen ist dabei den kampf
der systeme gegen den westen die usa zu
verlieren
in der lubjanka dem hauptquartier des
berüchtigten sowjetischen geheimdienstes
kgb verlangt der chef der hauptabteilung
auslandsaufklärung und spätere kgb
vorsitzende eine neuausrichtung bei der
anwerbung von agenten in den usa
wladimir klitschko auch chef von
wladimir putin ist unzufrieden mit
seinen leuten er schickt ein memo an
alle auslandsstationen der inhalt
anweisungen um wertvollere agenten im
ausland in den usa zu rekrutieren ein
kgb oberst der in den 80er jahren zum
britischen geheimdienst mi6 überläuft
hat unter anderem eine kopie des memos
im gepäck
rolf mowat lassen beim kalten krieg
station chef der cia in moskau und
später so genannter maulwurf jäger des
amerikanischen geheimdienstes dass
donald trump ziel einer russischen
rekrutierungs operation war
daran hat er keinen zweifel als jemand
der während des kalten kriegs in der
sowjetunion gedient hat sage ich sie
hätten ihn niemals verpasst und das sage
ich in kenntnis von fällen über die ich
aus ganz offensichtlichen gründen nicht
sprechen darf
in denen amerikaner kontaktiert wurden
gezielte kontaktaufnahme wir nennen das
pech der russische geheimdienst kommt zu
dir mach dir ein angebot
sie hätten niemals die gelegenheit
ausgelassen jemanden mit diesem
potenziellen nutzen für sie anzusprechen
und er selbst hat sich angeboten bei
allem was er gesagt und getan hat und
natürlich nicht zu vergessen bei seinem
potenzial für geschäftliche
alles begann 1987 in diesem jahr macht
front eine reise in die sowjetunion nach
moskau und sankt petersburg
er ist wie er später erklärte als gast
von intourist der sowjetischen
tourismusagentur beim tourist handelte
es sich wie wir heute wissen um eine
front organisation des kgb er reist
dorthin um die möglichkeit auszuloten
intourist hotels der marke trump zu
bauen
und als er zurückkommt macht er ein paar
sehr interessante sachen als donald
trump zurückkehrt geht er in die
offensive sagte russlandexperte scott
gordon der rechtsanwalt hat nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
verschiedene ostblockländer bei der
korruptionsbekämpfung beraten und
verfügt über exzellente kontakte
es entstehe schon damals der eindruck
dass donald trump seine geschäftlichen
und politischen interessen vermischt
sofort einen sondierungs ausschuss ein
der die aussichten einer tram
präsidentschaftskandidatur aus
außerdem gibt er innerhalb von wenigen
wochen ungefähr 130.000 dollar für
ganzseitige werbeanzeigen in der new
york times der washington post und dem
boston globe in denen er die nato heftig
attackiert
[Musik]
mit dieser werbeanzeige ganz im sinne
der sowjetunion beginnt trump seine
politische karriere
natürlich hat er die nato auch während
seiner präsidentschaftswahl im jahr 2016
schlecht gemacht aber die nato mitten im
kalten krieg zu attackieren ja tom
petters tatsächlich getan gleich nach
seiner rückkehr aus moskau nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion weiten
sich trumps russland kontakte aus vor
allem im geschäftlichen bereich der
trump tower in new york wird zum
anziehungspunkt russische mafia
syndikate darüber hatte zdfzoom schon
2017 berichtet oligarchen aus den
ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken investieren
millionen in tram projekte oder helfen
aus wenn donald trump mal wieder
schwierigkeiten hat einen kredit zu
bedienen als donald trump präsident wird
blickt er zurück auf jahrzehntelange
beziehungen zu dubiosen geschäftsleute
und verurteilten gangstern mit
verbindungen in den russischen
machtapparats
parallel zum aufstieg donald trumps in
der republikanischen partei entdecken us
behörden immer intensiver werden der
aktivitäten der russischen geheimdienste
die sich noch verstärken als donald
trump zum präsidentschaftskandidaten
ausgerufen wird
der damalige fbi-chef gamescom er im
hearing vor dem us in hatte das fbi
untersucht die versuche der russischen
regierung die präsidentschaftswahl 2016
zu beeinflussen und das schließt eine
untersuchung aller verbindungen zwischen
einzelnen personen des tramp
wahlkampfteams und der russischen
regierung fbi chef james comedia die
spionageabwehr operation der behörde
leitet wird am 9 mai 2017 von trump der
gerade erst mal fünf monate im amt ist
gefeuert
einen tag später kommt es im weißen haus
zu einem ungewöhnlichen treffen
das den verdacht der im raum steht nicht
kleiner werden lässt
im oval office empfängt donald trump den
russischen außenminister und den
russischen botschafter in den usa
außer dem präsidenten ist kein
amerikaner im raum us medien sind nicht
zugelassen
die fotos schießt ein fotograf den die
russische delegation mitgebracht hat sie
ist es auch die die fotos veröffentlicht
und über das gespräch berichtet demnach
erklärt donald trump seinen gästen aus
dem kreml
er stünde unter großem druck wegen der
russland ermittlungen aber das problem
sei gelöst kommissar ein spinner er habe
dem fbi chef entlassen
das erste was mir durch den kopf ging
war
was machen die russen da im oval office
neben dem präsidenten ohne dass da ein
weiterer amerikaner anwesend das hat es
noch nie gegeben
und dann war da die nachricht dass er
mich einen spinner genannt hat
persönlich hat mich das nicht gestört
denn ich weiß dass ich kein spinner bin
aber aufgefallen ist mir schon dass er
über einen amerikaner so mit einem
unserer gegner spricht es war eine der
vielen verhaltensweisen die mich
nachdenklich gemacht hat darüber wie
unser präsident gegenüber russland denkt
und handelt
je länger die präsidentschaft dauert
desto irritierender wird das verhalten
des präsidenten während die
amerikanische justiz weiter ermittelt ob
und wieweit das tram team in den
russischen angriff verwickelt ist führen
trump und putin ein privates gespräch
ohne zeugen unter vier augen
ein vorgang wie es ihn in der us
geschichte noch nie gegeben hat niemand
weiß bis heute was die beiden besprochen
haben in der anschließenden
pressekonferenz macht trump aber zum
erstaunen der us ermittler eine klare
aussage zu den vorwürfen russische
einflussnahme auf die us-wahl meine
leute sagen mir sie denken es war
russland ich habe präsident putin
gefragt er sagt russland war es nicht
und ich sehe auch nicht warum sie es
hätten tun sollen und das verhalten des
amerikanischen präsidenten lässt sich
immer weniger nachvollziehen und
erklären am tag vor dem treffen mit
putin bezeichnete er die europäische
union in einem atemzug mit china als
feind amerikas in handelsfragen
immer wieder greift er die westlichen
verbündeten schaffen macht aus seiner
abneigung gegen sie keinen hehl und
überrascht die welt mit seiner offenen
bewunderung für autokraten und brutale
diktaturen wie kim yong jun
er legt sich mit den nato-verbündeten an
droht damit das verteidigungsbündnis zu
verlassen und er spricht sich immer
wieder für eine enge freundschaftliche
zusammenarbeit mit russland aus und das
obwohl russland in syrien der ukraine
oder afrika massiv amerikanische
interessen verletzt
eine der fragen die du dir im umgang des
präsidenten mit präsident putin stellt
ist warum fast jain mit platzieren
schuhen an
warum macht er das warum verurteilt er
russland nicht wenn es berichte gibt
dass russland in afghanistan kopfgelder
auf us soldaten aussetzt
warum verurteilte er den russischen
einmarsch auf der krim nicht sondern
macht das gegenteil sagt wieso ich
dachte das gehört sowieso zu russland
all diese dinge sind so wieder dem
amerikanischen interesse so gegen das
republikanische dogma
und dann fragst du dich was ist der
grund dafür
du weiß man war einer der
erfolgreichsten us staatsanwälte für die
us-regierung große betrugs und mafia
prozesse geführt
er war justiziar des fbi und schärfe mit
der sogenannten muller investigation
nach der entlassung von james cole
ordnet das us justizministerium eine
unabhängige sonderermittlungen an
unter leitung des ehemaligen fbi chef
robert mueller
der auftrag ist herauszufinden ob sich
donald trump oder sein wahlkampfteam
einer verschwörung mit russischen
geheimdiensten schuldig gemacht haben
und ob der präsident die aufklärung dazu
behindert hat am 22 märz 2009 10
übergibt robert müller wegen der
russland affäre neu eingesetzten
justizminister bilbao den geheimen
ermittlungsbericht kurz darauf
veröffentlichte auch chefankläger der
usa einen vierseitigen brief mit den
ermittlungsergebnissen wie er sie sieht
die untersuchung konnte nicht nachweisen
dass sich mitglieder des tramp
wahlkampfteams mit der russischen
regierung verschworen oder koordiniert
haben
und noch etwas macht will ba in seinem
brief und dann in einer pressekonferenz
später klagen der stellvertretende
justizminister und ich sind zu dem
schluss gekommen dass die beweise die
während der untersuchung des
sonderermittlers gefunden wurden nicht
ausreichen um dem präsidenten eine
behinderung der justiz nachzuweisen die
ermittler aber sind erstaunt über den
brief und die darin enthaltenen
interpretationen ihres ministers die
aussagen in dem brief waren an manchen
stellen irreführend und an anderen
völlig falsch er hat damit dem
präsidenten den rücken gestärkt
er hat mehr oder weniger klipp und klar
gesagt dass da nichts war das kein
amerikaner kam inklusive mit den russen
zusammen gearbeitet hat dass es dafür
keine beweise gebe
aber das ist nicht wahr das ist nicht
was wir gesagt haben und dann dass es
keine behinderung der justiz durch den
präsidenten gegeben habe haben wir erst
recht nicht gesagt ganz im gegenteil wir
haben gesagt dass es substanzielle
beweise dafür gibt dass der präsident
die justiz behindert hat
der präsident
fakt ist mehrere tram vertraute und
mitglieder des wahlkampfteams werden so
teils langjährigen haftstrafen
verurteilt
eine frage aber konnten die ermittler
nicht klären welche rolle spielte donald
trump selbst dabei was wusste er wie bei
der mafia prozess stoßen die ermittler
auf eisernes schweigen der tram
vertrauten und das hatte einen grund
mit präsenten der präsident kann mit
begnadigungen wedel
das ist verheerend für die
strafverfolger denn ein weg die du als
ermittler jemanden überzeugt zu
kooperieren ist und dass es keine
raketenwissenschaft ihm klar zu machen
dass sie eine hohe zu erwartende strafe
reduzieren kann wenn er mit den behörden
kooperiert begnadigungen für schweigen
in der russland affäre für die ermittler
ein weiteres indiz für die kriminellen
verwicklungen des präsidenten
das ist eines der dinge die wir im
zweiten teil unseres berichts dargelegt
haben als beleg für die hinderung der
justiz ich denke dass die ganze frage
der behinderung der justiz durch den
präsidenten von der neuen administration
genau untersucht werden muss und auch in
einer anderen zentralen frage sind den
ermittlern die hände gebunden
seit jahrzehnten springen russischer
oligarchen und dubiose geschäftsleute
ein wenn donald trump mal wieder klamm
ist wenn ihm in amerika keine bank bis
auf die deutsche bank auch nur einen
penny leid damit angegeben dass sie jede
menge russisches geld bekommen das sie
amerikanische banken nicht bräuchten
weil sie genug russisches geld hätten
es gab also eine tatsachenbehauptung die
gerechtfertigt hätte sich die sache mal
genauer anzusehen
eine behauptung von seinem sohn dem
trump unternehmen arbeitet als der
präsident erfährt dass die ermittler
seine finanzen überprüfen wollen
herausfinden wollen woher das ganze geld
für seine oft die astros
verlustbringenden geschäften wie zum
beispiel dem golfplatz im schottischen
turnberry kommt zieht der präsident eine
rote linie
er droht muller und sein team zu feiern
sollten sie diesen weg weitergehen
trump hat seine politische macht sehr
effektiv genutzt um die untersuchung
davon abzuhalten zu einer eindeutigen
schlussfolgerung zu kommen
mit politischem druck auf die justiz
werde es unter beiden aber wohl vorbei
sein meint scorten der viele politiker
in washington berät die
staatsanwaltschaften werden freie hand
bekommen
der druck auf sie wird aufgehoben den
wird es nicht mehr geben
er wird aufhören sie werden tun was das
gesetz und die professionelle ethik von
ihnen verlangen mit dem ausscheiden aus
dem amt verliert trump die immunität die
er als präsident der chef ankläger der
staatsanwaltschaft in new york city hat
die zentralen fragen der maler
untersuchung aufgenommen
seine bankgeschäfte und ein paar andere
dinge mehr steuern zum beispiel eines
taxis konstanz donald trump könnt ihr
den rest seines lebens vor gericht
verbringen angeklagt wegen bank und
steuerbetrug geldwäsche aber auch
vergewaltigung verleumdung und
vorteilnahme im amt werden ihm
vorgeworfen
doch auch wenn donald trump in der
versenkung verschwinden sollte das
investment in seine präsidentschaft habe
sich für putin ausgezahlt meint rolf
mowat lassen indem sie unsere demokratie
diskreditieren indem wir unsere
demokratie durch unser chaos und
dysfunktionalität diskreditieren können
putin jinping und andere diktatoren
behaupten schaut mal die haben keine
ordnung keine kontrolle
diese sache mit der meinungs- und
redefreiheit ist außer kontrolle
alles fake news ich denke sie haben
einen riesen fortschritt gemacht ihre
position zu stärken dass das was sie der
welt anbieten besser ist als das was wir
anbieten
kein us-präsident hat während seiner
amtszeit das land so geschwächt und
amerikas gegner dabei so gestärkt wie
donna und donald trump sei da sind sich
viele beobachter einig für russland und
wladimir putin und dessen projekt die
westlichen demokratien zu schwächen oder
zu zerschlagen immer ein idealer partner
gewesen
ultimatives projekt war es innerhalb von
acht jahren zum amerikanischen putin zu
werden und dann für immer an der macht
zu bleiben
das verstörende an der sache ist er
wollte alles nur für sich selbst
es gibt nichts was donald trump nicht
getan hätte um seine eigene macht zu
stärken wenn er einen vorteil darin
gesehen hat dafür mit putin und russland
zusammenzuarbeiten
dann hätte er es getan dass donald trump
immer die nähe zu wladimir putin gesucht
hat daran besteht kein zweifel
aber es bleibt die frage ob es in dieser
beziehung ein dunkles geheimnis gibt
[Musik]
denn eine antwort auf die frage ob
feinde der demokratie bis in die
höchsten ämter aufsteigen können
entscheidet auch was amerika westliche
demokratien tun müssen um sich vor
angriffen dieser feinde von außen und
von innen zu schützen
[Musik]